and I tell the students when I when I
give talks to students I say isn't that
amazing that that in in your whole
course of biology and your developmental
biology textbook there's not a mention
of any of this because it completely um
uh just undermines a lot of the basic
assumptions so so here's a couple of
examples one one example is that as of
trophic memory and deer so there are
species of deer that every year they
regenerate you know the whole so they
make this antler rack on their heads the
whole thing falls off and then it
regrows the next year so these two guys
bubenic which are the Father and Son
team that did these experiments for 40
years and uh and actually have all these
antlers in my lab now because when when
the younger one retired I I asked he
sent me all these things all these
antlers the idea is this um what you can
do is you take a knife and somewhere in
this Branch structure you you make a
wound and the bone will heal and you get
a little callous and that's you know
that's it for that year then the whole
thing drops off and then next year here
it starts to grow and it will make an
ectopic tine an ectopic Branch at the
point where you injured it last year and
this goes on for five or six years and
then eventually it goes away and and and
you get a normal normal rack again and
so the the amazing thing about it is
that you know as you you could you can
you can the the standard models for for
patterning for morphogenesis are these
kind of um Gene regulatory networks and
and you know genetic um Kinds of Kinds
of uh biochemical gradients and so on
you know if you try to try to come up
with a with a with a model for this so
for for encoding an arbitrary Point
within a branch structure that your
cells at the scalp have to remember for
months after the whole thing is dropped
off and then not only remember it but
then implement it so that when the bone
starts to grow something says oh yes
that's the you know the start another
another time growing to your left
exactly exactly here right trying to
trying to make a model of this using the
standard tools of the field is uh just
just incredibly difficult and this is
that that's and there are other examples
of this but this kind of
non-non-genetic memory that's just very
difficult to explain with standard
models the other thing which is any I
think an even bigger Scandal is the
whole situation with planaria
um
planaria some species of planaria the
way they reproduce is they tear
themselves in half each half regenerates
the missing piece and now you've got two
that's how they reproduce so if you're
going to do that what you end up
avoiding is weissman's barrier this idea
that when we get mutations in our body
our children don't inherit those
mutations right so this means that any
mutation that doesn't kill the stem cell
in the body gets Amplified as that cell
contributes to regrowing the worm so
every as a result of this for for 400
million years these plenary have
accumulated mutations their genomes are
an incredible mess their cells are
basically mixoploid that meaning meaning
they're like a tumor every cell has a
different number of chromosomes
potentially they just they just look
look you know it just looks horrible as
an end result you've got an animal that
is Immortal incredibly good at
regenerating with 100 Fidelity and very
resistant to cancer now this is all of
this is the exact opposite of the
message you get uh from from from a
typical course through through biology
which it says that what is the genome
for The genome is for setting your body
structure if you mess with the genome
that information goes away you get you
get aging you get cancer right why does
the animal with the worst genome have
the the the best anatomical Fidelity I
mean that's just that and and I think we
actually as a as of you know a few
months ago we actually I think have some
insight into this but but but it's been
bugging me for for years and this is the
kind of thing that nobody ever talks
about because it it goes against the
general Assumption of what of what
genomes actually do and and what they're
for and you know this this complete lack
of uh correlation between the genome in
fact an anti-correlation between the
genome quality and the incredible
ability of this of this animal to uh to
to to to have a healthy Anatomy you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy